sabemos que exponerse a ciertos agentes
puede incrementar el riesgo de autismo.
En particular, hay una medicina, el ácido valproico
que las madres con epilepsia a veces toman,
que sabemos puede incrementar el riesgo de autismo.
Además, pueden haber agentes infecciosos
que también causan autismo.
Y una de las cosas en las que
me centraré mucho
es en los genes que pueden causar autismo.
Me centro en esto no porque los genes
sean la única causa de autismo,
sino porque es una de las causas
que podemos ya definir
y podemos entender mejor la biología
y entender mejor cómo funciona el cerebro
de manera que podemos diseñar estrategias
para poder intervenir.
Uno de los factores genéticos que no entendemos,
sin embargo, es la diferencia que vemos
en términos de hombres y mujeres.
Los varones se ven más afectados con autismo,
con respecto a las mujeres en proporción de 4 a 1.
Y en realidad no sabemos la causa de ello.
Una forma en la que podemos entender
que la genética es un factor
es mirando algo llamado
la tasa de concordancia.
En otras palabras, si un niño tiene autismo,
¿cuál es la probabilidad
que otro hermano en esa familia tenga autismo?
Podemos ver particularmente esto
en tres tipos de hermanos:
gemelos idénticos,
gemelos que en realidad comparten un 100%
de su información genética
y compartieron el mismo ambiente intrauterino
con respecto a gemelos,
a gemelos que en realidad comparten un 50%
de su información genética,
con respecto a los regulares,
hermano-hermana, hermana-hermana,
que también comparten un 50% de información genética
pero no el mismo ambiente intrauterino.
Y cuando observamos los índices de concordancia,
una de las cosas sorprendentes que pueden ver
es que en los gemelos idénticos,
su tasa de concordancia es del 77 %.
Sin embargo,
no es del 100%.
No es que los genes sean responsables de todos los riesgos de autismo,
pero representan una gran parte de ese riesgo,
porque cuando vemos a los gemelos fraternales,
la tasa de concordancia es solo del 31%.
Por otro lado, hay una diferencia
entre esos gemelos fraternos y los hermanos,
sugiriendo que hay exposiciones comunes
entre los gemelos fraternos
que pueden no ser compartidos comúnmente
con los hermanos solos.
Esto nos brinda algunos datos
de que el autismo es genético.
Bien, ¿y cómo de genético es?
Al compararlo con otras condiciones
con las que estamos familiarizados,
cosas como el cáncer, enfermedades del corazón, diabetes,
de hecho, la genética juega un rol mucho mayor en el autismo
con respecto a cualquiera de otras condiciones.
Pero con esto, no nos dice cuáles son los genes.
No nos dice ni siquiera en un niño
si es un gen
o una combinación potencial de genes.
Y en realidad, en algunos individuos con autismo
¡es genético!
Es decir, que es un solo,
poderoso y gen determinístico
que causa el autismo.
Sin embargo, en otros individuos
es genético, esto es,
que es en realidad una combinación de genes
en parte con el proceso de desarrollo
el que a fin de cuentas determina el riesgo de autismo.
No sabemos de ninguna persona, necesariamente,
cuál de las dos respuestas es
hasta que escarbamos más profundamente.
Así que la pregunta sería,
¿cómo podemos empezar a identificar
qué genes exactamente son?
Y permítanme plantear
algo que puede no ser intuitivo.
En ciertos individuos,
que puedan tener autismo
por una razón que es genética
pero todavía no a causa de autismo presente en la familia.
La razón es porque en ciertos individuos,
que en realidad pueden tener cambios genéticos o mutaciones
que no se transmiten de la madre
o del padre,
sino que comenzaron en ellos,
mutaciones que están presentes
en el óvulo o el esperma
al momento de la concepción
pero que no se transmitieron
generación tras generación en la familia.
Y en realidad podemos usar esa estrategia
para ahora entender e identificar
los genes que causan el autismo en esos individuos.
De hecho, en la Fundación Simons,
tomamos 2 600 individuos
que no tenían antecedentes familiares de autismo
y tomamos a esos niños y a sus madres y padres
y los usamos para tratar de entender
¿cuáles eran los genes
que causan el autismo en esos casos?
Para hacer eso, de hecho, tuvimos que
ser capaces de ver toda la información genética
y determinar cuáles son esas diferencias
entre la madre, el padre y el niño.
Haciendo esto, me disculpo,
voy a usar una analogía obsoleta
de las enciclopedias más que Wikipedia,
pero voy a hacerlo para tratar y ayudar a mostrar el punto
de cómo hicimos el inventario,
tuvimos que ser capaces de ver
una cantidad masiva de información.
Nuestra información genética está organizada
en un conjunto de 46 volúmenes,
y, teníamos que ser capaces de revisar
cada uno de esos 46 volúmenes,
porque en algunos casos con autismo,
solo falta realmente un volumen.
Tuvimos que hilar más fino, sin embargo,
y tuvimos que abrir dichos libros,
y en algunos casos, el cambio genético
era más sutil.
Podría haber sido un solo párrafo que le faltaba,
o incluso, más sutil que eso,
una sola letra,
una en tres mil millones de letras
que se cambió, que se alteró
pero que tuvo profundos efectos
en términos del funcionamiento cerebral
y que afecta el comportamiento.
Al hacer esto con las familias,
fuimos capaces de revisar aproximadamente
25% de los individuos
y determinar si existió un solo
factor genético poderoso
causante del autismo en esas familias.
Por otro lado, hay un 75%
que todavía no hemos descubierto.
Aún así, mientras lo hacíamos
fue realmente una lección de humildad,
porque nos dimos cuenta de que no había simplemente
un solo gen para el autismo.
De hecho, las estimaciones actuales
son que hay entre 200 y 400 genes diferentes
que pueden causar autismo.
Eso explica, en parte,
porque vemos un espectro tan amplio
en términos de sus efectos.
Aún cuando hay muchos genes,
existe algún método para la locura.
No es simplemente al azar
200, 400 genes diferentes,
que de hecho encajan.
Ellos encajan en una vía.
Encajan entre sí en una red
que empieza a tener sentido ahora
en términos de cómo funciona el cerebro.
Estamos empezando a tener un enfoque de abajo hacia arriba
donde identificamos esos genes,
esas proteínas, esas moléculas,
entendiendo cómo interactúan entre sí
para que la neurona funcione,
entendiendo cómo las neuronas interactúan juntas para
que el circuito funcione,
y entender cómo funcionan estos circuitos
para controlar el comportamiento,
y entenderlo, tanto en las personas con autismo
así como en los individuos que tienen cognición normal.
Pero un diagnóstico temprano es clave para nosotros.
Poder hacer ese diagnóstico
en alguien que es susceptible
en un tiempo, en una ventana
donde tenemos la capacidad de transformar,
para poder tener un impacto
el cultivo, el desarrollo del cerebro es fundamental.
Así que colegas como Ami Klin han desarrollado métodos
para ser capaces de tomar infantes, bebés,
y usar marcadores biológicos, así,
el contacto visual y seguimiento ocular,
para identificar a los infantes en riesgo.
Este infante en particular, se puede ver,
hace muy buen contacto visual con esta mujer
mientras ella está cantando "Witsi, Witsi Araña",
de hecho no desarrollará autismo.
Sabemos que este bebé está a salvo.
Por el contrario, este otro bebé
desarrollará autismo.
En este niño en particular, pueden ver,
que no hace un buen contacto visual.
En lugar de enfocar los ojos
y tener esa conexión social,
mirando la boca, mirando la nariz,
mirando en otra dirección,
pero nuevamente sin conexión social,
y siendo capaces de hacer esto en una escala muy grande,
examinando a los bebés, a los niños por autismo,
a través de algo muy robusto y confiable,
será muy útil para nosotros
para poder intervenir en una etapa temprana
cuando podemos tener mayor impacto.
¿Cómo vamos a intervenir?
Probablemente será una combinación de factores.
En parte, en algunos individuos,
probaremos y usaremos medicamentos.
Y así, de hecho, la identificación de los genes del autismo
es importante para nosotros
para identificarlos objetivamente,
para identificar cosas que puedan tener impacto
y estar seguros de que eso es lo que
tenemos que hacer en el autismo.
Pero esa no será la única respuesta.
Más allá de solo medicamentos, utilizaremos estrategias educativas.
Los individuos con autismo,
algunos están cableados un poco diferente.
Aprenden de otra manera.
Absorben su entorno de otra manera,
y debemos ser capaces de educarlos
de una manera que les sirva mejor.
Más allá de eso, hay muchos individuos
en este salón con grandes ideas
sobre las nuevas tecnologías que podemos utilizar,
desde dispositivos para entrenar el cerebro
para hacerlo más eficiente
y compensar las áreas en las que
tienen algunos problemas,
hasta cosas como los Lentes Google.
Imaginen, por ejemplo, a Gabriel,
con su torpeza social,
podría usar Lentes Google
con un auricular en la oreja,
y tener un entrenador capaz de ayudarlo,
ayudarlo a pensar acerca de las conversaciones,
iniciar conversaciones,
ser capaz de tal vez, algún día
de invitar a una chica a una cita.
Todas estas nuevas tecnologías
ofrecen enormes oportunidades
para que seamos capaces de impactar
a las personas con autismo,
pero todavía tenemos un largo camino por recorrer.
Por mucho que conocemos,
hay mucho más que no sabemos,
por lo que invito a todos Uds.
a ayudarnos a pensar en
cómo hacerlo mejor,
de como comunidad usar nuestra sabiduría colectiva
para hacer una diferencia,
y, en particular,
para los individuos de familias con autismo,
los invito a unirse a la red de autismo interactivo,
a ser parte de la solución a esto,
porque necesitará de muchos de nosotros
para pensar en lo que es importante,
y hará una diferencia significativa.
Mientras pensamos en algo
que sea potencialmente una solución,
¿qué tan bien funcionará?
¿Es algo que marcará la diferencia
en sus vidas, como individuos,
como una familia con autismo?
Necesitaremos personas de todas las edades,
desde jóvenes a adultos,
y con todas las formas y tamaños
de los trastornos del espectro autista
para asegurarnos que podemos tener un impacto.
Así que los invito a unirse a la misión
y a ayudar a hacer las vidas
de las personas con autismo
mucho mejores y más ricas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)